Billy is with us in Mississippi hi Billy
how are you
welfare are you better than I deserve
what's up well I got a tricky question
for you of not gonna fit on your in
because I'm sure you've heard it all but
I'm kind of a gambling addict or forming
one hopefully got some debt from that
other things through my 20s I'm 32 now I
have a two-year-old so now kind of woken
up and realized it where I don't need to
be wasting my money away
my wife's though four years is still
have the looks at me the gambler which
you always will so we have her account
my account and our account I heard a
couple weeks ago you were talking to a
woman about after you're married at
y'all's money it's no longer isn't heard
it's yours it's y'all it's you and her
together I don't think I can
how do I get her to because I've been
listening to you since I was a child my
mom maybe two and then I got out of it
and I'm back into it on satellite radio
but how do I get her to see that
together this is better for all of us
all around well let's face it she
doesn't trust you yeah oh that's what it
comes down to and so um I don't agree
that she will always look at you as a
gambler someday she will look at you as
a former gambler hmm when you've been
former long enough to earn the trust so
how long since you've gambled about a
year and a half up and in that time I've
paid down I want to say right at $12,000
in gambling debts on a few lines that I
had up you know again we can always get
money so few things I've had here and
there but I've closed everything out and
paid on pretty regularly a good portion
worked overtime and stuff too to get all
this clothes out like I said have a
two-year-old and I want for you so you
know I want to be put on that and put on
stuff aside placing very good good for
you and so I'm a year and a half and how
much have you paid off in a year and a
half
our 12-part say 12 to 15 I can't exactly
okay you usually you use the phrase um
addict you really believe you're an
addict or you going to GA well no that's
that I've never heard I like if I'm in
and out of your program listening to it
I was a driver but I've never heard you
speak on game with I don't know if you
consider gamblers addicts I would say no
I'm not because if you've now gotten if
you've not gone and seen a counselor who
said you're an addict and you're not
going to Gamblers Anonymous and you've
quit for a year and a half you probably
were not an addict yeah okay okay that's
what I would I don't need it I don't
have to have it I don't search for I've
had opportunities to go within this year
and a half and I said no and not God
okay so I would say that I'm in a better
place that I was I yeah I like that and
I don't disagree with you so it sounds
like you were just pretty heavy into it
but you weren't because I mean there's a
there's a part of people's brain that
flips over like like they were doing
drugs or something that's addict
okay and sometimes somebody can walk
away from that but most the time they've
got to have some help to walk away and
you just walked away so I'm guessing you
were just like you you weren't addicted
you were just over the edge and into the
area of really bad judgment like so you
were in the stupid zone but you weren't
in the headache zone is what it sounds
like that sound right yeah yes I have
agree that no kind of cool then I
thought that's it because that's a
different situation so I would not use
the phrase addict then around you and I
would not tell you to use it with her
and if she called me I was I would tell
her now I'm not a professional counselor
you could sit down with one if you
wanted a technical judgment on that but
I just deal I've dealt with gambling
addicts for years and so on I just and I
they can't stop I mean like somebody
can't stop doing cocaine you know I'm
saying
and so without help they can stop but
they have to have somebody to guide them
through it and you know go to Gamblers
Anonymous meetings like someone goes to
Alcoholics Anonymous meetings those
kinds of things to to begin to work
their way through it so having said all
of that then what I would say is this I
want you
all to begin to heal your marriage
you've been healing yourself on the
gambling
you've been healing your finances and
going back and you know paying cleaning
up the mess you made and that kind of
stuff but I want the two of you to start
talking about and you may sit down with
your pastor if you don't have one
find a local church and sit down with a
local pastor or get a marriage counselor
and sit down with them and go okay what
have we got to do so that we have a that
that gambling is in the rearview mirror
in our relationship and what period of
time what amount of money what
milestones have to happen this is you
asking her maybe with somebody like a
pastor sitting there asking or two
before she's okay with you combining
because if you're completely dry and
responsible for 10 years and she won't
combine girls incomes and work together
there's something wrong with her at that
point yes well also she she doesn't she
had a bad first marriage so she's okay
that's something wrong with her yeah he
doesn't want to come I'm sorry I just
she doesn't like to combine money
because she doesn't want to be on a
budget but I wanted I want to realize
that's a different subject I'm talking
about you started this whole
conversation up she didn't combine
because she doesn't trust you because of
your gambling okay okay at what point is
that trust rebuilt and so what I want
the two of you to do is I'm going to
participate in the healing on your
relationship and her healing from that
former marriage burning her and all the
stuff y'all are going through because
you're moving into a whole wonderful
good phase of your life and this
two-year-old has done it it's awesome
yes and so I want the two of you to go
through our class Financial Peace
University can you get her to go if I
give it to you uh if yeah I'll try my
best I mean I would love to go don't go
without her because it'll cause problems
okay
yes because you're going to come home
and wipe your finger in her face if
you're not careful because I'm going to
show you how to do stuff right and
you're going to want to do it yes and
she's going to want to do it too so just
tell her it's completely free it's part
of your marriage healing from her former
marriage scars and from your game
bling scars it's time for us now to be a
healthy complete couple for the good of
this baby yes see what you see how I'm
looking forward I'm not looking at her
past I'm not looking at your past we're
looking into the future at a positive
wonderful hopeful future and that's what
you're headed towards brother that's
what's going to happen for you guys you
deserve it y'all are ready you threw
your shoulders back and took control you
manned up I'm proud of you
very well done hold on Kelly's going to
pick up and she's going to get you guys
signed up for that class and I want you
to talk her into going you tell her it's
free tell her you take her out to dinner
okay you need to go and it's only nine
times once a week for nine weeks it'll
rock your world dude this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]